a brazos de nuevo en el aeropuerto de
oakland viajeros de 60 países
completamente vacunados y con pruebas
negativas de kobe 19 pudieron ingresar
al país sin necesidad de pasar por una
cuarentena o un aislamiento los primeros
que llegaron desde san francisco y los
ángeles fueron recibidos con danzas
maoríes y chocolates
o increíble ha sido un largo largo largo
tiempo de espera espera han sido dos
años en suspensión de solo preguntarse
si y cuando y nunca saber si el momento
y validad nueva zelanda impuso algunas
de las restricciones más duras del mundo
durante la pandemia con estrictos
controles fronterizos como parte de los
esfuerzos del gobierno por mantener
alejado al coi 19 pero a pesar del
empeño una variante de omicron se
expandió por todo el país ahora el
gobierno tiene la esperanza de impulsar
el turismo y aliviar la escasez de mano
de obra de todas formas la apertura es
gradual sólo los turistas de países con
extensión de visados con estados unidos
gran bretaña singapur y casi toda europa
podrán visitar ahora nueva zelanda en
las primeras horas de esta mañana
marcamos otro gran momento en nuestra
reconexión con el mundo con la
reapertura de nuestras fronteras a los
visitantes con excepción de visado entre
febrero y marzo las fronteras ya habían
sido abiertas a neozelandeses y
australianos
de dónde viene soy
de londres han pasado dos años y medio y
tres años mucho tiempo
es la primera vez que el bebé se
encuentra con la familia
aquí vamos ya tiene 18 meses
la mayoría de turistas de india china y
otros países que necesitan visado
estarán autorizados para entrar a partir
de octubre